what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so I'm sitting here thinking on whether
or not I'm going to cover blackboard X I
mean we have a little while and we've
got a little bit and truth my main goal
with guardians of the galaxy stuff this
week I mean we are still going to do
things like aliens nightmare asylum
we're like the Xenomorphs infest earth
and different things like that but in
terms of the Guardians content we're
going to be doing my main emphasis is to
basically give people like the runs of
guardians of the galaxy so we just kind
of start with businesses run and go all
the way up to right now this moment in
Marvel Comics so people can see how we
got from point A to point B and they can
basically be caught up on the Guardian
so they have all the information they
need if they want to go out and start
buying books at the very least be aware
of what's going on by the time the movie
comes out so with regards to the stories
right now we're actually kind of you
know junk for a little bit and we're
going to focus on the idea of all the
guardians of the galaxy becoming venom
it's really really cool one thing to
keep in mind is that in the last video
we had talked about how Flash Thompson
had basically been sent to the guardians
of the galaxy by the Avengers following
the events of superior venom of course
we'll talk about that video or I guess
we'll do that video on Monday but with
regards to Flash Thompson who is really
like more of an envoy for the Avengers
with the Guardian so he would be able to
kind of segue back and forth between the
two groups and he was just a way for the
Avengers to keep in contact with the
Guardians because the guardians were
always kind of running around the galaxy
and different things like that the issue
was that once the Venom symbiote was
taken by the scrolls and then recaptured
by flash he chose not to rejoin the
guardians instead he decided to kind of
go back and make his own way now the
reason for this is because of the fact
that had he gone to the Guardians and
said look I want to go back to Earth
that probably wouldn't have happened I
mean he was there to be an envoy who was
there to fulfill a job and the Guardians
probably would have made him finish that
job but for slash his desire was to
always go back home he just kind of had
enough of being out in space and that
made sense with regards to Flash
Thompson as a character I would surmise
it he probably felt a little more at
home on earth than he does out in space
because he has a solid grasp you know
space is uncharted territory while this
wouldn't normally matter for various
superheroes for Flash Thompson it's kind
of a big deal because he's just sort of
out there in no-man's land and so while
he's overhearing a discussion about some
number of the Kree talking about how
he's been to earth of course his goal is
to return it slowly this venom simius
essentially kind of loses its mine and
begins attacking this guy desiring to
have information on how to return to
earth down for
when this kreega isn't able to provide
that information that Flash Thompson
needs the Venom symbiote effectively
kills them and so again for here we kind
of switch over to Katie pride in
star-lord this is kind of a cool thing
is because the two of them are currently
in a relationship right now you know
again a lot of these about things came
out of like the Infinity storyline and
you know superheroes crossing over who
wouldn't necessarily cross over
different things like that but the
relationship between the two was always
kind of cool because Peter quill was
just like a wildly irresponsible person
right like I mean he's the last person
he'd want to go on a date with because
he just isn't a responsible human being
in a lot of ways she's still very
childish she has yet to really grow up
but the the environment of the Guardians
lends itself to that mindset in the
sense that he can be brash he can be
reckless he could go out there and be
kind of crazy at the same time Kitty
Pryde is the opposite she's very
responsible she's very resourceful you
know she's a large part of the x-men
community right now now of course this
could very well be just kind of wishful
thinking right like Kitty Pryde like man
my life is really boring I want to live
through star-lord I want to go out into
space and I want to be reckless and
irresponsible and different things like
that again it's kind of funny you know
with regards how these characters mesh
but it's very much the idea that
opposites attract the issue here is that
they're not physically with one another
instead QT prides here is a hologram
it's the only way they can really
maintain a long-distance relationship
now the other half of this is the Peter
quill is spilling a lot of truths that
he believes will basically solidify the
strength of their relationship the
problem is that the truce he's spilling
are a problem he's basically telling
Kitty Pryde when things get stressful
like he sleeps around and like he sleeps
around a lot and I don't know why you
would tell the woman that you're
interested in that you do that but the
bigger point that he's trying to make
here is that of all the women he's ever
been with the Kitty Pryde is the one
that has the biggest impact on him the
most now the way he could have gone
about telling her that could have been a
little bit better I mean I wouldn't
really sit down on a date with a woman
and say hey look I've been with hundreds
of women I've been with so many women
but you are the greatest woman that I've
met most women would not be receptive to
that they would say okay well that's
cool but I've got a friend who has an
emergency and that emergency requires me
to be anywhere but here right now so
because of that actually basically just
bail out but again it's also this idea
that the guardians are still kind of out
there they're so kind of doing their own
thing it's really one of these R&R
right leg work the guardians are
together 100% of the time there are
times when they go out and they just go
and do their own thing now in the midst
of this remember we had talked about
this bartender the flash Thompson and
interaction destroyer first ran into
when flash was basically given new
weapons this guy who's basically dealing
and illegal arms trades but Flash
Thompson it goes back and visits this
bartender because his bartender seemed
to express information that he knew a
lot about the history of the symbian now
of course flash trying to get this
information out of him it doesn't
initially work of course this is
compounded by the fact that Gamora shows
that remember she's just kind of out
doing her own thing but when she finds
flash her responses look we've been
hunting all over the galaxy for you we
were trying to find you forever where
did you go well without a word the Venom
symbiote immediately attacks now the
funny thing about this is that we're
actually going to find there's a lot
more going on here than what initially
seems to be taking place whereas it
seems like the venom Samiha is kind of
taking on a life of its own and it's
just attacking indiscriminately but
there's actually going to be something a
little more taking place which is
actually really cool the way that then
just builds this in but the Venom
symbiote seems to be speaking more so
than flash and the venom to be as
basically saying things like hey you
brought me out here because you didn't
want me to be on earth you consider me
to be a danger you guys want to ruin me
you guys want to destroy my purpose
corrupt me as being like a superhero on
earth or you guys you're doing is
ruining everything now of course this
eventually leads into Flash Thompson
more or less taking over control of the
Venom symbiote and then in turn the
Guardians arriving and stripping him of
the venom Sabine itself so of course the
two are basically isolated from one
another now this is where bender starts
to focus on this indeed and it's kind of
cool because we had never seen anything
like this in Marvel comics there's never
been an instance what a writer sat down
and said you know what let's explore the
nature of the Venom symbiote let's make
you let's make it more than just some
thing that attacks you don't attaches
itself to some guy and then decides it
wants to kill Peter Parker let's do a
little bit of exploring let's we'll do a
little bit of testing the waters let's
see what we can do with this small
little tidbit of the Marvel landscape
that's wildly popular and so while on
board the guardianship it's actually
kind of funny when it happens because
there's one of these things you could
really see in the movie you know where
Rocket Raccoon is kind of focused on
different parts and different things you
know he's like hey look can you help me
with this so we can figure out what's
going on with this M because the entire
time it's contained although the
symbiote basically breaks loose and
attaches itself to Groot and so roots
hums venom and it's it looks so cool it
looks so amazing Oh is one of the
coolest things that's going to happen
now while this is taking place this
stage is actually being set for another
story coming up again this is what
bindus does Ben just will usually say
hey look here's a story we have going on
but we're going to plant the seeds we're
going to go throw in a little tip that's
you know a few little goodies here and
there so we can segue into another story
so the basically overlapping events are
overlapping stories but it's not done in
a confusing way it's done in a way that
works but basically following the events
of the ousting of JSON of spartax the
fact that he was basically kicked out as
the emperor once Peter basically
broadcast out to the galaxy that Jason
was going to kill his own son to
maintain his own power then the question
becomes Oh who's going to rule smart axe
in his step and the answer that's given
by the ruling body is that it's going to
be Peter quill the issue with this is
that he does not have to be present and
he does not even have to run for
election in order to be appointed
president he's just appointed to that
position and then taken in made
president so as almost he has no choice
in the matter which is kind of
interesting of course we're going to see
that come to fruition later on and
that's really going to kind of set the
stage going into all-new all-different
marvel with regards to the new guardians
of the galaxy has been reformed and you
know Kitty Pryde and that kind of a
thing but you know getting back to the
guardians the funny thing is people are
just like what in the heck is going on
why is Groot venom and it's kind of
funny because all Groot says is I am
venom that's the only thing he says so
it's kind of cool that we get to you
know get this whole idea maintained of
how he goes or how he functions in
relation to being venom in the sense
that is still very much the same group
that we were always aware of now the
other cool thing about this is that he's
able to go toe to toe like Drax a
destroyer Gamora so on and so forth it's
kind of cool to see it happened but it's
not unheard of back in the Incredible
Hulk annual number 5 before Groot became
a character as we know him he was just a
giant tree villains really all he was
you know a floor colossi and because of
that he was actually a member who at was
it wrote the story but he was used or
recreated really by some crazy guy and
was one of like six villains to go
against the Incredible Hulk and so we
actually have to see a story or brute
fights of the Hulk and that story will
be covered do not worry Rob gore I will
not leave you hanging we will see the
story of Groot versus the whole but the
fact remains here that with regards to
the to the symbiote it's still very much
just the symbian nature in and of itself
its weaknesses you know the various
issues like that so of course where Drax
is initially able
overcome the venom scimitar at the very
least purge it directly from from grew
by quite literally just kind of punching
it in a weak spot the venom should be it
then turns around and attaches itself to
Rocket Raccoon which is cool like it's
really kind of kind of funny to see now
of course this comes after the venom
Cydia sort of escapes through the
tunnels or through the through the
ductwork and so on and so forth but
rocket as venom looks really awesome now
it looks really cool now here's what we
get a little bit more information in
terms of what's going on here I mean
it's been this isn't just simply saying
hey what would it look like if the Venom
symbiote was attaching to like the
different members of the guardians of
the galaxy the Venom's to me it's
basically wanting to kick everybody off
the ship and then go back to its home
planet kind of side tracking for a
second we actually end up picking up
with Carol Danvers I remember during
Kelly's suta comics run her goal was to
remove Carol Danvers from Earth and make
her a tried and true captain marvel that
traversed the spaceways and dealt with
prawn kind of all over the galaxy so of
course she's basically within the realm
of nowhere you know within the bar of
nowhere just kind of hanging out
stopping criminals who are committing
crimes robbing people different things
like that but then she basically comes
across a giant broadcast as they squid
and said that Peter Quill's been
appointed to president of Spartak so
again kind of funny to see is a little
bit little of a tidbit but again Peter
doesn't know about any of this you know
he's not aware that any of this is
happening instead he's dealing with
rocket racoon like rocket groot for
rocket the rocket venom almost with
rocket groot i would love to see a
rocket racoon and like groot headway
that'd be kind of cool to see but uh but
the fact remains that rocket racoon of
course again is basically apprehended
immediately by Drax naturally what
happens then just takes this pretty
quick in terms of the venom soviet
jumping from one person to the next
but when Drax seizes control of the
Venom's to be it then Drax himself
becomes venom now this is kind of
interesting because again the narrative
remains the same you know as GRU the
Venom symbiote couldn't communicate
itself you know when it took over rocket
the venoms to be upset but you guys are
getting off this ship and I'm heading to
a to a different location with Drax
seizing control of rocket and then
becoming venom Drax himself takes out
the rest of the guardians of the galaxy
and then basically takes the entire
group back to the planet of the simius
now the cool thing about this is this is
when Bendis basically begins to explore
everything and what we end up finding
out here is that the Venom symbiote was
actually functioning according to what
it needed to do but it was also very
much corrupted and that's kind of the
crazy thing here is what they do once
they actually emerge out into you know
the planet symbian itself is it a planet
is
entirely composed of symbionts you know
whether it's bondage of things whether
there's somebody's to take on a life of
their own the planet is basically simpie
it at its core and that's what's so cool
about this is I guess we never knew this
all we knew was that this symbiote just
kind of popped up in the original secret
war story we never knew where it came
from it bonded itself to Peter Parker it
was brought back to earth and the
adventures of venom and carnage started
after that it was just that's it that's
all we had that's all we knew and that's
why this story is so cool because it
gives us a bunch of that information it
gives us a lot of those things now I
Misha Lee the opportunities offered to
the members of the Guardians to allow
themselves to bond with the symbionts
now we're not initially told why we're
somebody just home look the symbiotes
are extending an olive branch and we can
either join them or we can just kind of
hang back in the ship now for Flash
Thompson shares a kind of kinship with
with the symbionts that no one else has
and so he immediately just kind of
allows himself to bond with it and this
is when he sort of times up and says hey
look guys basically bonding with us is
the only way they can communicate the
symbiotes cannot communicate in the
sense of using vocal patterns or
anything like that the symbiote is
basically communicate by using a host
and so for the rest of the guardians
begin to jump in this is when we start
to learn the purpose of the symbiote so
what we find out is that by their very
nature by their very definition the
symbionts are neither good nor evil
they're essentially just kind of benign
beings that exist but they serve the
purpose of creating more or less an
intergalactic police force the problem
with this is that in order for them to
fulfill their true purpose they require
a house who's basically of good moral
fiber and physically pure and so they
have to be good guys in every sense of
the word literally metaphorically the
whole nine yards Peter Parker was a
reflection of that the issue is that
Peter Parker chose to cast a symbian off
and the symbiote itself began to hate
Peter Parker and that's the way these
two things function that's kind of the
retcon
the Brian Michael Bendis is throwing in
here under normal circumstances one
assembiy it and a host bond and perfect
harmony the character going forward is
of force to be reckoned with but if
there's any kind of corruption if the
person is inherently evil or if they
become evil they will corrupt a symbiote
and the symbian will take on a life of
its own
effectively becoming a bad guy now of
course this offers a bootstrapped
explanation in terms of the Venom
symbiote giving birth to carnage card is
becoming a bad guy
and things like that but the fact
remains here that because of the fact
that there have been instances where the
symbionts have bonded themselves to
people and in turn basically become bad
guys it's led to this reputation within
the galaxy that the symbiotes are
inherently evil the difference with this
and one of the things have been to
offers here is a Flash Thompson was the
perfect host in a sense that because of
the things that Flash Thompson had done
in his past because of the fact that he
had lost his legs in the military it had
offered him a new lease on life and with
the Venom symbiote he'd sought
Redemption he sought the idea to make
himself a good guy and so he was able to
effectively kind of bring the Venom
symbiote back towards the road of
redemption removing it away from the
realm of being a villain and
transforming it into a good guy and so
because of this the other symbiote look
on to Flash Thompson and say you are the
you know basically a perfect host you
are the kind of being that we look for
when it comes to us bonding to one
particular person so what they do is
they effectively upgrade a symbiote
that's really what it is they upgrade
the Venom symbiote and then restore it
to them and so what it does is it allows
them to kind of go forward with a whole
host of new abilities they never had
before now of course this segues
directly into venom space knife it's
really what that does but the idea here
is that it's basically kind of Bendis
using the legacies in the history of the
symbiotes themselves to essentially
jumpstart and move forward the legacy of
Flash Thompson as venom you know the
legacy of agent venom in order to make
him someone new now this is not like
regrow limbs or anything so his legs are
still gone but it still allows him to
basically function as an intergalactic
force as an intergalactic guy who's able
to sort of you know be a hero the reason
why that was done was because of the
fact that the agent venom line of
stories was kind of moving towards a
place of stagnation and myths in that
you could only do so many stories fans
wanted to see something new fans wanted
to see things kind of move in a new
direction it doesn't mean they didn't
like agent then a fans love the agent
venom but it's one of those things pay
luck look into the future there's only
so many stories that we can do and so
let's kind of get ahead of the curve and
let's begin the process of moving venom
away from being an earth-based hero and
give them a new line of stories and
we'll just kind of see what happens from
there the issue is that once he got into
venom space design a lot of people
didn't really care for too much and that
kind of led to the downward spiral of
venom going back to Eddie Brock and that
kind of that kind of a thing it was a it
was kind of a sad turn of events a lot
of people are really upset that we don't
get agent venom anymore and
lot of people are really upset at Flash
Thompson isn't venom anymore I mean in
truth if I remarked how they would have
made him Flash Thompson I like the idea
of Eddie Brock even them now in Marvel
now to point out but I understand that a
lot of people really want agent then and
they come out there were great stories
man they were good stories it was cool
to see like it was a cool concept from
novel to create so I wouldn't mind
seeing agent venom come back but I am
kind of glad the Venom symbiote is back
with Eddie Brock at least in Marvel now
2.0 person I have that video here on my
channel and you can find it down in the
description but in any event what the
story does is basically just kind of
segues into what the next story will be
the next video will do where it turns
out that Peter quill basically learns
hey man you've been elected president of
Spartak good luck dealing with that one
but anyway guys we're going to bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comment explain make sure you hit the
sub button to become part of the rod 4
if you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you